hello this is Justin with the chess
website today I'm going to be talking
about the gundum defense this is not a
very common opening not something you're
going to see a lot but I wanted to talk
about it because I think it's really
important for understanding how to
punish bad openings so I would consider
a bad opening any opening where they
ignore the opening principles so they
aren't developing their they aren't
castling um stuff like that so the
Gundam defense starts with E4
E5 Knight to F3 attacking the pawn and
here there's a lot of different ways to
defend the pawn the most common and
classically proven to be good is Knight
to
C6 but here the Gundam defense is Queen
to E7 so trying to defend this Pawn like
this so the reason that this is not
considered a good opening is because
instead of developing uh your your minor
pieces your Knights and Bishops you're
bringing your queen out early and
typically bringing your queen out early
isn't great because your opponent can
attack that Queen while improving their
own pieces so for example if I had a
knight on C3 here I could bring this
Knight to D5 centralizing the Knight and
gaining Time by attacking that Queen so
now black has to spend time to deal with
it so anyway after Queen to E7 um the
best way to punish this kind of opening
where they aren't developing their
pieces like uh
naturally we want to make sure that we
prioritize our development so we get a
lead in development we have more pieces
out than they have and we also once
we're set up once we're castled we want
to try to open up the center so I'll
show you how uh an example of how this
can be done so we we just develop our
Bishop naturally this is a very normal
move bringing our Bishop to a nice
Square essentially eyeing this F7 square
and also allowing us to Castle in the
next turn so now Knight to F6 they're
attacking this Pawn so again we want to
develop quickly so we play Knight to
C3 perfect now we brought another piece
out and we dealt with Bo's
threat so black if they're they're smart
is going to keep trying to develop um so
another downside of bringing the queen
to E7 is it blocks this bishop usually
this bishop wants to come out this way
but with this queen in the way it just
can't do that so a plan that might make
sense for black would be to try to get
this bishop out this way maybe get the
bishop to G7 instead however if they do
this it starts to run into some issues
so if they play G6 now we can right away
punish um this bad opening by playing
Knight to G5 so we've seen this kind of
idea with the Knight and the bishop
lining up on this F7 Square in openings
like the fried liver attack now here
black really doesn't have a great way of
dealing with it because the only way to
stop us from taking on F7 is to play a
move like D5 and in response to this we
could just take it um and typically
black has some sort of
compensation um in return for giving up
this Pawn
um but in this case they really have
nothing because we are so far ahead in
developments and black has a hard time
getting their pieces ready to Castle we
have ideas of playing D6 with the idea
of opening up that Bishop towards
F7 uh a lot of very dangerous ideas here
for white so Knight to G5 is very
dangerous um but for example if black
played Knight to C6 here again they're
trying to to keep Pace they're trying to
keep developing their own pieces
but if we just Castle they really can't
keep Pace there's no developing move
here um for black that improves their
position so for example like they would
love to develop these Bishops next but
there's no bishop move both of their
Bishops are blocked by their own pieces
so it's going to take them more time to
get developed and on top of that we've
already got three versus two pieces
developed plus we're castled so I
consider that you know four V too so
white has a huge lead in development and
should have a very nice position here so
let's look at if we tried to still be
aggressive and play Knight to G5 so here
we can do this um there's nothing
terribly wrong with this but um there is
a little weird looking trap here um that
I wanted to show so if we got too
aggressive too quickly before we castled
black might try to do something like
play
H6 and this looks kind of weird because
they're just inviting us to take on F7
so the idea isn't actually to attack
this Knight the idea is to seal the exit
for the Knight so here this Knight has
no way of returning back into the game
all of these squares are covered so all
black has to do is play a move like Rook
H7 and eventually they're going to be
able to cral this night um and they're
just going to say it's trapped so weird
very
bizarre Night Trap here but um black is
actually okay here so we have to be a
little careful um it's just best to keep
things simple in these kinds of
situations and develop our pieces so we
just Castle everything's going to be
okay so now after D6 this is really the
point I wanted to emphasize when our
opponent is playing a bad opening how do
we punish it we punish it by opening the
center if we can open up the center our
pieces will have more scope and they'll
be able to shine in that position when
the position opens up while our
opponent's pieces stuck on the back rank
not really having developed are going to
kind of be seen in in a greater light
and that um lack of development will
stick out like a sore thumb so try to
think about how how would we open up
this position
if we were
white so here the the move I really like
here is to play
D4 so we're striking in the center right
there's this tension
here but again the reason we're doing
this is because we have this massive
lead in
development and right away because we're
castled we have three or four pieces
developed versus blacks 2 um opening up
the center or trading and allowing uh
more lines to be opened up um so for
example if if block did nothing and then
we played a move like D5 this would be
an example of closing the center because
the pawns are are stuck they can't
capture they can't move forward it's
just it's really rigid and tight and
that we call those positions closed
positions so we want to open up the
position so that happens when there are
Pawn captures in the
center so after e takes D4 we take back
with the Knight and there's already a
trap setup here um so if you have a lead
in development things are just going to
work out for you like there's just going
to be tactics that work in your favor um
and this is an example of that so here
if blacka okay I've got two attackers on
this pawn and you've got one Defender
and they went ahead and took this Pawn
that would be a huge mistake because we
could just take back they have to take
with the queen and again um with the
second move we saw the queen and the
King lined up on this e file and so
right away we should be thinking okay
how do we how do we take advantage of
that so here in this example we were
able to open up e file and now we can
finally take advantage of that and play
Rook to E1 which pins the queen to the
king and should win the queen and the
game so this is a little trap we set up
here
and if they don't take say they do
something more normal maybe they take
they bring our Queen out um this is a
little different because our Queen uh
like bringing our Queen out in the
opening because our Queen isn't uh able
to be attacked very easily um if there
was a knight that could come to C6 here
um maybe you know the queen on D4
wouldn't be that great but they just
traded that Knight so our Queen is
actually quite um protected here on D4
even though it's right in the center of
the position um so we've already
succeeded in opening up the position we
have a leading development um so again
black is trying to catch up trying to
develop their own pieces but we can take
advantage of our better pieces um and
the fact that this king is still in the
center that's a very big factor if that
King doesn't get castled that's going to
cause serious problems for black so we
see that right away with this move
Knight to D5
this already puts black in a very
strange predicament because if they take
on D5 either with the Knight or the
bishop they're going to open up this e
Line towards that queen and king which
we just saw can be very very detrimental
so after Knight to D5 black doesn't have
a lot of options because if they played
a move like Queen D7 well now we have
one two attackers and they only have one
Defender because that Queen was
defending that Knight on top of that if
they play a move like Queen D6 to keep
an eye here we have this crazy looking
move Bishop to
H6 just
insane just leaving the bishop on pre
because if they do take it we have
Knight takes F6 anytime our opponent
moves a piece anytime we move a piece it
is not defending a square that it was
once defending so here that pawn was
defending that six square and now it's
not cuz it took on H6 so it allows this
this king is dead in the water and uh it
it the game should be over very quickly
we could probably win this Rook on h8 as
well um so very very
deadly and after Knight to D5 again it's
just very difficult if they move the
queen there's lots of issues and then if
they take on D5 we take back and then
just like I said before we get to open
up this e file and we're going to be
very happy so we just normally develop
our pieces we're threatening Rook to E1
we couldn't play Rook to E1 right here
because nothing's protecting it that
would be a very bad way to uh hang a
rook so we have to protect it first we
play Bishop D2 now both the rook and the
bishop are looking at that square and
here Black's position is so bad that his
best move is to play King to d8 which is
just so so sad um because there's just
not a good way to get out of this uh pin
with the Rook so for example if they
castled well this Rook was defending
something and now it's not so Queen
takes A7 comes very deadly threatening
Queen A8 Checkmate on the next
turn um so they can't Castle they'll
play Move like Queen F6 we're going to
check anyway and he probably has to play
King d8 if they played something like
like this um we can just pile up the
pressure on the E file keep that King in
the center because if they ever castle
that King was once defending that bishop
and now it's not so we're just going to
win free piece so we see there's a lot
of ways for black to go wrong and all we
did was we developed we castled and we
opened up the center so that's the
recipe for Success when our opponent
plays a bad opening such as the Gundam
defense so if you ever see your opponent
not developing not castling not
following those opening
principles now you know you want to open
up the center you want to blast open the
position so your pieces can shine
through and dominate your opponent's
position thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next video